Louis Philippe Ouimet.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Sourire en coin, Charlie Watts
était la force tranquille
des Rolling Stones.
♪ ♪ ♪
BREEN LEBOEUF, bassiste
du groupe Offenbach
- Pour moi, c'est Charlie
qui tenait les Rolling Stones
pendant toutes les années
où les drames...
STEVE HILL, guitariste et
auteur-compositeur-interprète
- Né à Wembley, en Angleterre,
Charlie Watts était un
passionnée de jazz qui a appris
seul à jouer de la batterie.
En 1963, il a rejoint
les Rolling Stones et,
jusqu'à la fin, il a été
derrière ces tempos
inoubliables du groupe.
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ I can't get no ♪
- La façon qu'il jouait,
c'était tellement "clean",
c'était tellement propre,
et les trous que ça...
que ça donnait pour
la musique des Stones était...
c'était ça, la commande.
- Charlie Watts avait
une "swing" qui date
d'une autre époque,
que les... il n'y a plus ça,
puis c'est une façon de...
mais tu l'entends.
- Réservé, Charlie Watts
maintenait un certain équilibre
dans la vie "rock and roll"
des Rolling Stones.
Lui, qui a eu la même conjointe
pendant 50 ans, n'avait rien
de flamboyant, nous dit
le producteur Serge Grimaud.
♪ ♪ ♪
SERGE GRIMAUD, producteur de
spectacles, The Rolling Stones
- Il avait un super sens
de l'humour, c'était vraiment
une personne qui se promenait
dans une arrière-scène et puis
qui impose, de par son aura,
une espèce de respect...
de respect immédiat, quoi.
Une personne exceptionnelle.
♪ ♪ ♪
Malade, le musicien avait subi
récemment une opération
et il avait annoncé qu'il ne
participerait pas à la prochaine
tournée de son groupe.
Le jour de son décès,
les hommages fusent de toutes
parts, entre autres du batteur
des Beatles, Ringo Starr.
Le site des Rolling Stones a été
fermé, laissant comme seule
image celle de Charlie Watts.
J'ai pratiquement pleuré quand
j'ai appris la nouvelle parce
que pour moi, ça me fin des
collections.
- Je ne sais pas comment
ils vont continuer sans lui.
Mais on a été chanceux de
l'avoir jusqu'à l'âge de 80.
♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est seulement du rock
and roll, mais ils ont été
nombreux à aimer le son unique
de Charlie Watts. Sans lui,
les Rolling Stones ne seront
plus jamais les mêmes.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
- Poursuivons avec Mike
Gauthier. Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- Il y en a qui dise que c'est
la fin des Stones. Ils repartent
en tournée d'encaissement et
c'était prévu qu'elle fasse en
lui. Est-ce que c'est la fin du
groupe quand même?
- Je dirais qu'il faut savoir
qu'il y a quelques jours, on a
écrit que les Stones préparent
une tournée qui pourrait
considérer une tournée date de
l'année prochaine. Le but c'est
de jouer dans des endroits et
des monuments historiques, par
exemple à Paris ce serait en bas
de la tour Eiffel qui ont fait
le tour du monde pour dire au
revoir au fans. On a appris
aujourd'hui que Charlie Watts
décédé. Dans l'entourage, on
avait déjà eu des nouvelles à
cet effet et on s'est dit : est-
ce qu'on va finalement... c'est
peut-être qu'on avait préparé.
C'est lui qui va le remplacer.
C'est un batteur. Keith avait
travaillé dans les Laurentides
pour son premier album solo.
Les Stones voulaient finir cette
tournée et je l'impression que
ça va faire 60 ans
- ce serait une vraie vraie
tournée d'adieu. Et la mort de
Charlie Watts est le prélude de
sous tout ça.
- Possiblement. Après 60 ans,
oui, c'est beau Hamas et des
millions de dollars parce qu'on
fait des tournées. Pourquoi ne
pas finir en beauté? Moi je
trouve que de donner des
concerts dans des endroits qui
sont historiques, c'est une très
bonne idée et ce serait une
belle façon de dire que c'est
terminé et que l'aventure, il y
a beaucoup de personnes qui
disent que le fait que Charlie
Watts s'en va, ça va
sensibiliser les autres à
tourner la page sur cette belle
histoire du rock.
- On ne sait pas si le stade
olympique est considéré comme
lieu historique. Est-ce qu'ils
viendront à Toronto? À suivre.
Je veux revenir sur le style. On
l'a vu dans la chanson, le côté
pour reprendre l'expression dans
le reportage clean, sec.
- Comme disait Steve Hill, il a
bâti le son des Stones mais
Charlie Watts aussi avec la
station rythmique avec sa façon
de jouer la batterie. Il a
permis au groupe d'avoir leurs
propres sons. Il y a des
chansons que j'aime beaucoup
même au début des années 60, il
était différent Charlie Watts.
Les riffs qu'il a développés au
niveau de la batterie. C'est
intéressant. Même sur un album
de 1989, il était vraiment
intense et il était vraiment
bon. Il a vraiment donné une
couleur. Tu entends une chanson
du groupe et tu reconnais tout
de suite grâce à la batterie ou
au rythme de Richards.